the saying is you know water is life
we're waterborne people
we depend on it
this fishing spot is ancient the mohawk
the ghania gahaga were fishing here
thousands of years before the first
european settlers arrived
this is aquazasna where the mohawk have
fished since long before this border cut
their nation in half
fishing in this community is important
i know
for our grandparents it was a way of
life
i believe in having those traditions
passed down so they've never forgotten
seeing those little boys and girls
smiling and catching fish and enjoying
themselves
[Music]
that's the best
yeah
if you head up river just a couple of
miles from this spot you'll find two
abandoned industrial sites this is the
spot where poisonous chemicals made
their way into the river
into the fish
and into the mohawk people
forty years later they're still carrying
that poison
and chances are
you are too
people used to live on the islands
themselves
totally self-sufficient
my grandfather used to live on san
francis island
he's the one that introduced me to
fishing
and
we would roll across the river the
shorelines were covered with weed bits
and it was a task to get our row boat
through the weed beds
we'd catch perch sunfish rock bass
he showed me how to clean fish
explained to me what it was all about
my grandmother used to take me out to
the berry gardens and we picked
raspberries and strawberries blueberries
out there
we had potatoes vegetables my
grandfather had a herd of calls just
about everything we needed that was out
there
i remember that
in the 1950s the u.s and canadian
government started a massive project to
connect the great lakes with the
atlantic ocean by widening and deepening
the saint lawrence river
the seaway
changed
the geography of aquizassney all the
trees on the affected area must be cut
down
there was an apple orchard there big
apple archer an old man the old man john
owned that
[Music]
and they said they were going to build a
bridge across they hadn't even consulted
him until the equipment came up the
seaway's locks and dams allowed giant
container ships like these to navigate
to the great lakes
and the dams supplied electricity which
the state of new york promised to sell
to companies for cheap every cent of
expenditures will be recovered through
total charges and revenue from the sale
of power in the long run it will cost
the people of two nations nothing the
press coverage focuses exclusively on
the benefits for canadians and americans
but there was a third nation whose
people were affected
a lot of our older people couldn't speak
english they couldn't understand
why how this could happen
how could a people do this how could
engineers do this
[Music]
when the seaway went through they were
informed they weren't asked what they
thought about this
power to run the machines
the motors
to light the signs
the homes
supply energy for the thousand and one
needs of an expanding economy there were
nine islands that were flooded there
used to be a bay inlet there was a
swampy area they filled that in
they said oh we'll do you a favor
what about the muskrats
what about the beaver
they're gone they're gone now
thus man is conquering another of
nature's challenges moving the atlantic
ocean to the entire mid-continent empire
when the frogs start to come out and
they start to make noise
that for me indicates that the water and
the ground temperature is right to do
the spear fishing
this is it this is the magic spot
so much life happens here
when you enter the water it's not really
good to walk where the fish are doing
their thing it's their if that's their
spawning bed that's where they want to
lay their eggs so it's pretty precious
space there
you gotta be gentle and you gotta be
selective
just recognizing you know that it's
that it's a gift
you should just respect it you know
and just having that gratefulness that
we're still able to do it you know
that's that's what i always get to them
with we're so lucky
really really
this is what i know
i'm the oldest son so i have little
brothers all night i teach them this
stuff
the mohawk creation story says at the
beginning of time
the whole world was covered in water and
there is no land
that's when sky woman falls from the sky
she falls to the earth with a child in
her belly
the ducks and the loons and the geese
decided that they would try to help her
from falling straight into the waters
in the end it was the giant turtle who
said that he could put the soil on his
back she could land on his back and as
she danced in the circle as she shuffled
her feet on the dirt it expanded and
expanded
our people give thanks to the water they
see it as an essential part of who we
are
new york's plan to lower industry
upstate with cheap electricity it worked
two major corporations general motors
and reynolds medal built factories in
the mostly white town of messina right
next to aquazasner according to the
local newspaper messina's politicians
and business leaders reacted with joy
but for the mohawk of acquisner the news
meant something else entirely
soon after the new factories opened in
the late 50s
mohawk farmers on cornwall island
started to notice their calves weren't
growing as well then the cattle started
mysteriously dying off
later it turned out that 400 pounds of
fluoride ash was spewing out of the new
reynolds plant every hour veterinarians
discovered it had poisoned the grass and
eroded the cow's teeth making it too
painful for them to eat or drink
they were starving if you look across
the history of settler colonialism in
areas where indigenous people remained
and still lived corporations working
under the laws of the united states were
able to dump the most dangerous
chemicals and pollutants there while i
was in early practice
doing home births here
there was a cluster of babies born one
baby born with an omphalocele which is
where the intestines grow
outside
the belly another was a baby born with
no intestines at all
and they had to let that baby die as an
anecdote
it still gives you a sense of where's
this heading that is polychlorinated
biphenyls which are used in a wide
variety of manufactured products pcbs
started showing up in american news
stories in the late 1960s when they were
discovered in salmon and poultry at the
time there was just one manufacturer of
pcbs in the us
the monsanto company of st louis
they marketed the chemical under the
name aeroclore and sold it to other
companies who then used it to make
products like shower curtains paint and
electrical equipment
including the electrical equipment in
those plants the ones gm and reynolds
had built right next to aquazasna
[Music]
in 1971 a monsanto representative told
the new york times that the company was
studying the chemicals effects on rats
and dogs
so far they said
no ill effects had yet been detected
but monsanto's internal documents from
that time tell a different story
they knew that pcbs caused liver damage
in rats they knew that pcb exposure had
sent workers to the hospital with
symptoms of hepatitis and in 1970
one of monsanto's own studies on pcbs
and fish showed that doses of pcb which
were believed to be okay
produced 100 percent kill
all the fish died
you know eating a certain food isn't
just putting
the stuff in your mouth
it's what goes on all around
that moment of consumption
my mom would tell me stories about how
my father and his family would have
these like fish skinning
competitions
and
it makes me so happy to think about how
that was in itself like a way that we
created community and family for each
other and supported each other
with
really good friends a really good family
members we've known them for a long time
we trust them we know that they respect
our independence and our consent in
indigenous
ways of understanding the world we can
use
that
way of thinking about relationships as a
model what would it mean to have
relationships of trust
with
fish relationships of reciprocity with a
forest for consent with a plant
our community is not just the humans but
all of our interdependent relationships
when we teach our children about
giving thanks that's what we're trying
to do is to get them to see that they're
not just a fish but they're fish
and these fish help us to maintain our
life
[Music]
in 1981 two pits full of pcb sludge were
discovered behind the gm factory near
aquazasne prompting scientists to start
testing local wildlife
at the time
chickens with pcb concentrations of more
than five parts per million couldn't be
sold in supermarkets but most of the
fish in aquizassna had levels much
higher
30 parts per million is considered toxic
waste
researchers tested one snapping turtle
with a pcb concentration of
835 parts per million
it turned out both gm and reynolds had
been dumping pcb waste into the saint
lawrence river for decades
we were just straight up told
to not eat fish that we would die they
were telling us that the tomatoes that
were coming out of the garden shouldn't
be eaten by children so a lot of people
just stopped
farming all together
i remember
talking to an older lady from the island
here she actually burst into tears and
she said when i go down to the
the shoreline
to look for sweet flag it's not there
i look for my sweet grass it's not there
what have they done
to this place
the the plants the animals the
ecosystems
are thought of as as part of the bonds
part of the friendships and imagine if
somebody were
to take something that was
really important to
a friendship a family relationship that
you have and just pollute it
and just damage or destroy it
that that hits us hard right that's
devastating
but see this is what native people have
been through with colonialism
a systematic comprehensive destruction
of all of those touchstones in our
society those environments that formed
the contexts
through which our best relationships
unfolded we lost pieces of our language
of our value system with the river
because of our disconnect because of
these fish advisories and so right now i
can't recommend people to consume fish
because that's our policy but personally
i'm like we have to consume fish so we
know their names and so we reconnect
with them
there was an existing relationship that
they had with everything that the water
system provided it was part of their
life
and it was taken away it changed all of
a sudden it wasn't there
in the decades since pcbs were
discovered scientists documenting the
scope of the pcb problem outside of
acquisner people all over north america
were told not to eat the fish from the
rivers streams and lakes where they
lived
scientists also learned that pcbs can
move from the soil into the air through
a process called volatilization
which means that even if you don't live
near a pcb dump you can still be exposed
through the air that you breathe
in 2013 the un's international agency
for research in cancer stated officially
pcbs are carcinogenic to humans and they
are probably in the body of every human
on earth
i can't
do too much
given our current reality
but i can go out there in the morning
and sing
one day
a day
to be
to be grateful
you come from
the ground up right and you give thanks
to everything
[Music]
the roots the trees the plants
the skies the winds the stars
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a river has a right to community and to
build community around itself
and i think a lot about how that's our
responsibility as ongoing people to
facilitate that
there was a little boy ice fishing and
he was putting the fish in a big plastic
bucket
and we saw him at the end of the day
take his bucket and run home with it
[Music]
and i wondered
what is his mother gonna say when she
sees all the fish her little son caught
she's gonna be proud of him
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
you